hi thanks for joining this virtual
conference my name is John Berger and I
am the manager of the development team
of sister madre in this virtual
conference you will learn the basics of
system model it will be divided into
four separate sessions in this the first
session I will introduce the basic
concepts or the the tool it will give
you an idea of how you could be using
the product in the following three
sessions my colleague Patrick Eichenberg
will take you step by step from learning
how to similar to ready-made models to
creating your own models using
drag-and-drop taking you from the level
of model consumer to model developer
this part will be more hands-on and you
will be able to follow along if you have
system order installed on your computer
and repeat what Patrick is doing doing
all the over the sessions you will be
able to ask questions through the chat
and Patrick and I will be replying them
directly in the chat or orally in
between sessions depending on the
question the Wallow system own is huge
and modeling can mean many different
things you might use pen and paper to
draw a model or something use some CAD
tool or even a 3d printer or you might
be developing mathematical models for of
different kinds the method will depend
on the type of system you are studying
and the task in hand so let us look at
what system or focus on system or is
developed to study the dynamics of
systems or even systems of systems the
system can be something relatively
simple such as a pendulum or something
more advanced such as an aircraft or a
propulsion we start by looking at the
aircraft example we might want to study
its flight dynamics or in
case of life science we might want to
look at the population and see how
sickle cell disease is spreading through
a population
you
we distinguish between two different
types of usage as a model developer you
develop models either for your own use
or for someone else to consume as an
example you might be teaching population
dynamics and would like your students to
be able to explore how different traits
affect a population then you can develop
a virtual lab consistent model of user
interface that allows the students to
explore the traits here we can see how
we are step-by-step through
drag-and-drop building up and model for
studying of sickle cell anemia so we are
setting a a name for a new component
giving it a description and once we're
happy with the description we apply that
and we might want to set some connect
connected to the rest of the system of
course and once connected we'll set
parameters as we would like as a user I
could then receive something like this
notebook where the developer has given
instructions on how to use it and I can
fill in different things like the
probability that sickle cell child will
be will be born and that will affect the
results in in some virtual lab that we
have set up and here we can see we have
sliders to change different properties
in the model and we can look at what
happens if we are in a malaria and they
make population or not
so creating virtual labs is one reason
for using system models but of course
there are more if we take virtual labs a
bit further we have training simulators
which try to replicate the behavior some
real-world system another key area is
model-based design where you can use
models for explore design space various
virtual test systems design controllers
and many other things of course so
what type of requirements does this set
for a modeling tool well from the
example of usage in the previous slides
it is obvious that just being able to
model and simulate it is not enough you
need to be able to do things like
analyzing your system develop user
interfaces for virtual labs calibrate
parameters and so on
furthermore you would like the model to
natural mirror the system action model
this makes it easier to build maintain
and share this means that you often need
to mix multiple kinds of domains for
instance an electric kettle model might
need combination of electrical and
thermal models along the same line you
need to be able to combine continuous
and discrete behavior yes as real-life
system would sister model is built from
the ground up to meet these demands so
let us look at them one by one beginning
with the last one let's get back in time
a bit and look at the good old-fashioned
trebuchet the actual throwing a flight
of the stone is best model as a
continuous system while the logic for
how the catapult is governed might be
better modeled as a discrete process
furthermore you would probably like to
model the bouncing as discrete events in
system or ease you can easily combine
these two as shown by the animation of a
very bouncy stoner I mentioned an
electric kettle as an example of a
system that requires components from
different domains so let's explore this
a bit further as you can see in the
model diagram we have pointed out four
different types of components
we have a resistor or thermistor that is
used to heat up the water so this
resistor is basically the coil in our
kettle and then we have the water here
we have a temperature sensor that takes
us from from thermal over to numerix and
that then numerix is used connected here
to a logic block or a girlfriend from
numerix to logical decision and this
logical operation or signal is fed back
to our opening switch where the logic is
used to control an electrical component
so we see this kind of loop of things
interconnecting different domains so
even if this is a very small system it
required a bunch of different domains to
be able to model it correctly as you saw
in the previous example the components
the system or a generally easy to easy
recognizable this is a key aspect if you
want to model a large system such as
this model of our other flaps in a
cessna conquest four-for-one in this
case the model developer has developed
his own components for the top level
model one component for the pilot one
for the electrical system one for the
flaps for the landing gear motor
hydraulic system and so on and you can
easily recognize them in in the top
level view you can also dig in to the
component by clicking on it so for
instance if we open the electrical
circuit we can see that is built up by
bulbs and wires sensors and so on and in
the same manner if we click into the
flaps we see that the flaps consists of
an hydraulic system and a mechanical
system that interact
and on top level all these systems
interact with each other of course
so this capability of having something
look and being organized as a real-life
system is crucial if you want to be able
to develop something large and
communicate that with others finally and
probably the most important aspect once
you have invested a time in developing a
model you would pro like to get as much
mileage as possible from it while
developing a model and simulating with
different parameters might be very
valuable in itself the ability of
creating virtual labs optimizing your
system performing sensitivity analysis
and so on is key to get that mileage
that is exactly what the combination
system order Mathematica gives you so in
this seminar we're focusing on on the
drag-and-drop and connect part that
enables all these and the kind of
one-click simulation but beware that
there's more to it in system model and
the Wolfram language it allows you to
full simulation control and the an
unlimited set of analysis and design
tools if you want to combine your model
your system model with machine learning
you can do that if you want to do
control design you can do that if you
want to document it you can do that and
so on so almost whatever you would like
to do is up to you how you want to
combine it and how you want to analyze
it and then of course you can share in
several different ways including through
the vault from language
so and that concludes my part of this
conference and I will soon hand over to
Patrick Eichenberg who will take you
through how you can start using system
or by exploring ready-made models how
you can use these models to modify them
and adjust them according to your needs
and finally in the last session of the
day how you develop your own models with
drag and drop all these sessions are a
bit more hands-on you will see the
actual tool in use and it will get it
give going in pace so you can follow
along if you have an installation on
your computer and as I said before
you're welcome to ask any questions to
reach out and we'll try to assist with
answers thank you very much